Children, children.
So, after landing on the moon, it's left to be invented.
He discovered everything.
She's right, they already invented everything.
Anyway, now we know it all.
Children, if you only knew how much there is still for us to discover, to understand,
the origins of life, of matter, the infinitely small, which we know so little about,
the way the brain works, as well as evolution of outer space.
In no time, your lives and those of your children will change.
Just imagine tomorrow, and after tomorrow, it's the year 2020.
...and soft-boiled egg for you, sir, as usual, hot chocolate bread and jam for you.
Mind you, sir, you are late. If I may say so, you're often late. All of you...
Nester, will you go bring me one of the apricots in the basket there?
Sir's teasing Nester again. Not funny.
You know, you're amazing, Nester. How are you able to do all of this?
Each one of my hands contains 6,000 microcaptus, sir.
For you, this is going to be a big day at the World Assembly.
Yes, I must be off.
To be there by 11 today.
And you?
As usual, I'll be working at the Planetary Research Center.
We left Washington a few minutes ago.
Our flight's suborbital, and we'll have crossed the Atlantic in 25 minutes.
Listen, Fred.
Absolutely essential that the World Assembly vote for colonization.
Position.
I know, Fred.
Always the same ones, but...
New school bags.
Right, with computers already integrated.
You know who is...
See the display screen, huh?
And the computer keyboard, naturally.
Laser printer, microphone, loudspeaker, and so on.
You press this button, and you're linked directly to the memory bank.
And you can request any information that you need.
Are there any questions?
This laser disc contains a library of 100,000 pages.
It's about 500 books.
You may insert it like this, and then you get your display on the screen.
Now, let's start our lesson.
And because now it's in the news, we'll talk about the planet Mars.
And we'll look at some of the holograms.
Mars, the planet will be man's next objective.
Can anybody tell me about it?
Now, of course, you can have the data instantly using the computer in your school bag.
Go on now, try them out.
Go ahead.
It's an 800 kilometers in diameter.
Yeah, so it is bigger or smaller than the Earth?
Uh, approximately two times smaller.
Correct answer.
Now, let's make a comparison.
What distance?
It, too, has an orbit around the sun.
The distance from Earth is constantly changing.
I'd call that an excellent answer, my dear.
Now, the sun, regarding Mars,
is located between 60 and 100,000 kilometers from Earth,
which is 200 to 300 times our distance from the moon.
For a long time, people believed there was life on Mars,
and little Martians, well, if we judge according to the size of this fault,
3 or 4,000 kilometers in length,
120 kilometers wide, volcanoes big as France,
and rising to a height of 27 kilometers, the little Martians would be giants.
Its atmosphere contains 95% carbon dioxide, deadly for living creatures.
But with today's technology, it won't be a problem.
Great, then let's all go.
One day, perhaps soon. The decision is up to the world assembly.
The thing that is today before the world assembly is an important one.
The colonization of another planet would commit future generations for more than a century.
The European delegate will speak.
aware our planet is no longer adequate the solutions which we have adopted in our previous
assembly namely cities in the sky floating cities cities underwater can't be a real answer to the
problem what's more the rising level of all the earth's oceans consequence of the greenhouse effect
will for several decades will concern millions of human beings the future of humankind demands
that we conquer other planets this project six hundred billion dollars in the cost of your
project where are you going to find the money like that in your own pocket or in
mine I warn you my country is not going to vote Mr. President may I continue with
my address may I request the delegate from California to refrain from
disrupting the proceedings and to wait until he has the floor this project will
require a dedicated and long financial commitment of the whole world our base
Liberty 400 kilometers above the earth is almost operational we will use it to
launch spaceships outside the earth's gravitational field our lunar base can
extract oxygen from its rocks and minerals and combustible fuels.
A nine-month journey one way plus the factor of the ellipsis 22 months
including all considerations, then the return no human can withstand all that.
The production of red corpuscles will surely slow down and no white cells
produced at all. It means anemia, calcium deficiency, with one sure result, weak
bones, hyperactive kidneys, and dehydration. Solar radiation is going to
give everyone cancer. Carefully noted all of the objections of the various
delegates but the system of artificial gravity equipping our transport vehicles is now perfected
eliminating many of the problems together with a full multi-band sun shield and the cost of the
project ever think about that the cost is of course very great but all this work will produce
techniques that are new and new materials and if we succeed in towing even one small asteroid to
earth's orbit the advantages will be beyond measure metals minerals enough to supply raw materials for
next 10 centuries then the operation in fact will be profitable the success of
this operation can't be guaranteed we can be sure of one thing price that I
guarantee you will be astronomical a preliminary exploration with robots will
mean we can test all elements of the program at a cost 50 times lower and if
preliminary tests all prove encouraging we will proceed with the colonization of
Mars has anyone anything to add then I now call for a vote on the proposal
which is at hand. Those who are for the project, 14. Those against, 14 in favor, 17 against.
The Mars project as amended is adopted. By majority, the meeting is closed.
Ice caps we see on Mars reflect the sun's rays like a massive mirror. I collected this seaweed
in our polar regions. Great quantities of this will be spread over the poles on Mars,
absorbing solar heat, and so furnishing heat to the planet and producing water. Look,
Our second step, studying the terrain by launching robotic detectors.
Like this one, we'll launch them from our moon base.
Then analyze the soil.
And the Liberty Base construction goes on.
Reserve your diploma. You are now spaceflight commander. Congratulations.
Thank you, sir.
It is with great pleasure I award you the highest certificate as space construction engineer.
Diploma of engineering biochemistry. Congratulations.
Engineer in spatial mechanics. Congratulations.
I know that whatever you build won't come down.
Turn.
The examination, laboratory work zero, conduct zero.
Well, my lad, maybe you can do better next time.
Right, right, I think me too.
Well, I guess I ought to come back as well.
It's an honored guest.
Peter, director of the Planetary Research Center, is with us today
and will report on the precise situation concerning Operation Mars.
Liberty Base, the cargo for Mars is at last ready.
Guidance will be by automatic pilot.
It will transport all the equipment and supplies we'll need
to make our first settlement on the Red Planet.
This is the primary base, the plane vehicle, the module for Mars landing, the engine for insertion into planned trajectory, propulsion vehicle for the cruise return.
Once the vehicle is off on a trajectory to Mars, another vehicle sets off, one that is very light.
It will leave Liberty Base with four astronauts. Being much faster, it will catch up with the first vehicle.
Meanwhile, on a lunar base, we are stocking up on oxygen from the lunar rocks.
Once the base on Mars is set up, this oxygen will be sent by electromagnetic capsules and by cargo vessels.
We're also researching radically new techniques for acceleration, including asteroid coupling acceleration.
You are all acquainted with the asteroid belt between Jupiter and Mars.
Many of these massive boulders wander into a region between Mars and Earth.
Our spaceships could develop a technique of harpooning, a sling effect.
Of course, speed would be considerably increased and it would improve the trajectory,
with the consequence saving in time, money, and resources.
It's a big waste! You're wasting all our money!
With regard to asteroids, it is my duty to inform you that surveillance telescopes have recently detected an asteroid that appears to be worrying scientists.
It seems to be headed straight for Earth.
It is approaching us at a speed of 100,000 kilometers per hour.
The object will stay on its course and will be in collision with Earth.
Difficult to say.
At present, it is approaching Mars.
It all depends on its trajectory, its angle of attack, into the gravitation of Mars, the Earth.
Answer the man's question, sir.
What are the chances of its hitting Earth?
Say, there's one chance in 10,000.
Bolts had to be tightened.
No broccoli. Guess what it is.
Say.
Then you'd be wrong.
This meat is from animals we've raised on the moon
to get us used to what we'll be eating on Mars.
All the same, it's not as good as a triple burger down on Earth.
With the preparations we're doing,
it's time we left. Do you agree with me?
We'll get our orders to go pretty soon.
President of the World Assembly, it's urgent.
There's a real danger that it will head straight for Earth.
If it did impact with our planet, it would destroy all forms of life.
We destroy it? Just set off an explosion?
Setting off an explosion too near Earth would be catastrophic.
Well, then...
A neutron bomb might knock it doors,
but the only craft that's operational with sufficient range is for the Mars project,
which is then compromised. So should we use it.
We have no choice. We must destroy this thing,
or else it's the end of humanity.
If you agree, I'll go to liberty immediately.
No time to waste.
My vehicle are being secured to your ship,
and they're going to be ready to go.
I'm sorry I have to do this, but now we have no choice.
It's the greatest danger of all time.
But it takes us on a completely modified trajectory, right, sir?
The region you'll be headed for is dense with asteroids.
If you find a harpoon site that's good,
then you may be able to get on to your original trajectory.
But sir, has it ever been done?
Yes, machines did it, only not always with success.
What are our chances?
Difficult to say.
But all of our observation stations are on full alert to help guide you.
Good luck.
Yes, Commander. It is unlikely they will ever return to their orbit around the sun.
We'll have to go to plan B. Bring them back around Venus.
Second, one second, Colonel. An asteroid's been spotted. Correct rotation.
In two days. Position. Astral degrees 66. 966. Good luck.
Because it's our nature to discover the universe.
Don't you recall Henry the Navigator's sailors, they wanted to go beyond the limits of the known world
where the sea flowed into a bottomless pit.
And all the discoverers we've talked about changed our world.
One day man will also transform Mars.
Transform it?
Just imagine.
Imagine.
The gases increasing up in quantities of polar ice as water.
Just as free as they'd be on Earth.
That's right, children.
With its nuclear engine on its way toward the star Barnard six light years away,
men and women will build other spaceships that might catch up with this one
before it ever reaches its final destination.
We will have great craft-priced solar light
that sail on lasers.
It's using nuclear fusion.
And why not?
Antimatter.
We'll travel at a speed approaching that of light.
300,000 kilometers per second.
A billion kilometers per hour.
Even farther into the future,
tachyon power 300 times faster still.
The only drawback,
you'd see your fellow passengers aging before your merry eyes.
Yeah, it's still only a distant dream, like all those fabulous craft I told you about.
But we have only to remember the fantastic progress mankind has achieved in one little century.
Who's to say he won't find someday all kinds of shortcuts to space-time,
so that it's possible to voyage to the stars tomorrow?